THREE YEAH. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE IT'S SAID TUESDAY
APRIL TWENTIETH. NINE OH FIVE
AM AND WE'LL WE'RE WILL BE
STARTING OUR ASSEMBLY AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE COMMITTEE BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT A COUPLE OF-
OPENING STATEMENTS I NEED TO
MAKE AND SOME DIAL IN
INFORMATION. SO DUE TO ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
GUIDANCE ON PHYSICAL DISTANCING
SEATING FOR THIS HEARING WILL
BE VERY LIMITED FOR PRESS AND
FOR THE PUBLIC WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM OR AT
A VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND THE
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA. SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF SPACING THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO PRODUCE
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC COULD NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO ONE
PERSON. AT A TIME. WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH- ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
OUR CALL IN NUMBER FOR
WITNESSES IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
PIN NUMBER IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. AGAIN
THE PIN NUMBER IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. THIS
CALL WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU PLAN TO TESTIFY ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. I WILL TRY TO
REMIND YOU WHEN TO CALL IN FOR
EACH BILL UP PLEASE DO NOT CALL
AHEAD THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED. IN QUEUE
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND ISSUES.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST
THE BILL YOU WILL REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE. AND WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK AUTHORS PLEASE
REMEMBER THERE ARE ONLY TWO
SUPPORT AND TO OPPOSE WITNESSES
PER MEASURE. IF YOU ARE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE NINE
ZERO AGAIN THAT NUMBER FOR THE
COMMITTEE IS. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE NINE
ZERO AND COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP- FOR
VIDEO WITNESSES IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE SOME BILL WITNESS
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESS CON VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
AND OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM. AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. I ALSO WANNA NOTE WE
ARE EXPECTS STEPPING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL WHICH
INSTRUCTIONS WITH INSTRUCTIONS
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND
YOU CAN FIND THE EMAIL FOR THE
COMMITTEE THERE AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. WE ALL
FACE UP WITH THAT LET'S DO ROLL
CALL SINCE WE HAVE OUR FIRST
AUTHOR PATIENTLY WAITING.
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM NAZARIAN
PRESENT PATEL YOU. ORDER FOR
THAT HOW. LACKING HERE READ
RUBIO HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO- WHY DON'T WE START WITH AB
FOUR NINE NINE THIS BLANCA
RUBIO. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BARREL FOR NINETY NINE
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL CREATE
CONSUMER PROTECTION ACT SENIOR
CARE REFERRAL AGENCIES.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES ARE
R. C. VI'S FOR THE ELDERLY ARE
NON MEDICAL FACILITIES THAT
SPECIALIZE IN HOUSING
PERSONALIZE A PART OF SERVICES
AND ASSISTANCE IN ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING. RCF EASE OUR
LICENSE INSPECTED AND REGULATED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. DURING COVERT
NINETEEN REFERRAL AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN A CRUCIAL PART OF
PLACEMENT DECISIONS FOR ELDER
AND DEPENDENT ADULTS AS
VISITATION IS EITHER NOT AN
OPTION OR INFREQUENT TO LIMIT
THE EXPOSURE OF RESIDENTS AND
STAFF. WHEN FAMILIES ARE
LOOKING TO PLACE A LOVED ONE IN
AN RCF ET THEY OFTEN TURN TO
REFERRAL AGENTS. REFERRAL
AGENCIES MATCH INDIVIDUALS TO
AN ASSISTED LIVING COMMUNITY
BASED ON THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF
THE INDIVIDUAL. THIS SERVICE IS
TYPICALLY AT NO COST TO THE
FAMILY WITH THE REFERRAL SOURCE
BEING REMUNERATED BY THE
FACILITY ITSELF. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW FOR
MORE TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESS OF
INFORMATION FOR CONSUMERS
SEEKING PLACEMENT A AT A
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY. AB
FOUR NINETY NINE SIX TO PROTECT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES BY
CODIFYING A NUMBER OF
REGULATIONS DURING A REFERRAL
SOURCES INTERACTION WITH THE
CLIENT AND INCREASE REGULATIONS
ON REFERRAL SOURCES. NOTABLY AB
FOUR NINE NINE REQUIRES
REFERRAL SOURCES TO PROVIDE
DISCLOSURES TO THE SENIORS OR
THEIR REPRESENTATIVES SOME OF
THE DISCLOSURES INCLUDE THE
REFERRAL SOURCES PRIVACY
POLICY. A STATEMENT ON WHETHER
THE REFERRAL SOURCE WILL BE
PAID A REFERRAL FEE BY THE RCMP
TO WHICH THE SENIOR IS
REFERRED. AND THE STATEMENT
THAT THE SENIOR OR
REPRESENTATIVE MAY REQUEST IN
WRITING THAT THE REFERRAL
SOURCE SEIZE CONTACT WITH THAT
SENIOR. OTHER REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDE THE CONDITION THAT
REFERRAL SOURCE EMPLOYEES NEED
TO UNDERGO BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THE MAINTAINING OF LIABILITY
INSURANCE AND ONLY CONDUCTING
BUSINESS WITH THE RCMP IF THERE
IS A WRITTEN CONTRACT. AB FOUR
NINETY NINE ALSO OUTLINES THE
CRITERIA OF ABUSE AND OR POOR
QUALITY OF TREATMENT FOUND
WITHIN IT R. C. F. E. BY A
REFERRAL SOURCE NEEDING TO BE
REPORTED TO THE APPROPRIATE
LICENSING AGENCY. THE BILL
ENJOYS WIDE SUPPORT AND IS THE
RESULT OF EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS ON THE LINE WITH
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
NINETY NINE OUR MONICA MILLER
AND CLIFF BURKE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MONICA DO YOU WANNA
GO FIRST. I'LL GAS SURE CELL
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK MONICA
NOW RECKON. EIGHTY WHEN I THINK
THE OPERATIVES BOB QUESTIONS. I
FOR ALL PUBLIC SECTOR. AT THE
STATE MINIMUM JOHN IT'S ABOUT A
COMPANY DATA THAT AFFECTS THE
COLLUDED FOR HELLO COUPLE OF
YEARS I'M EXCITED ABOUT TRUMP
ABOUT. MISTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CLIFF HERE FOR A-
PLACE MOM- FIRST OFF I DO WANNA
THANK- THE AUTHOR IN HER STAFF
FOR WORK CLOSELY WITH US ON
THIS BILL I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE
TIME THEY'VE IN WITH US ALSO.
WANT TO THANK MONICA MILLER AND
MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL IN BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. AND
FAMILIES TO PROVIDE. IN FOR
THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE AN
DECISIONS IF THEY FIND THE
RIGHT FACILITY FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS. OF BRIEFLY A PLACE FOR
MOM IS THE LARGEST NATIONAL
ONLINE SENIOR LIVING REFERRAL
AGENCY WITH HUNDREDS OF HIGHLY
TRAINED EXPERIENCED. AND
COMPASSIONATE SENIOR LIVING
ADVISORS LOCATED IN CITIES
ACROSS NORTH AMERICA. A PLACE
FOR MOM IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING FAMILY MEMBERS THE
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
AND FINDING THE RIGHT SYSTEM
LIVING FACILITY FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES. OFTEN AT A TIME OF CRISIS
BASED ON YOUR UNIQUE NEEDS AND
BUDGET A PLACE FOR MOM IS PAID
BY THE SINCE THE LIVING
FACILITY IN CARE PROVIDERS IN
ITS NETWORK. SO SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED TO FAMILIES AT NO
CHARGE. AS MONICA INDICATED IN
THE AUTHOR EIGHTY FOUR NINE
NINE IS THE RESULT OF OVER SIX
YEARS OF LEGISLATIVE
DISCUSSIONS. FALL STARTS- IN
POTENTIAL DISAGREEMENTS BETWEEN
INDUSTRY AND CONSUMERS OVERRIDE
EVE DIFFERENT BILLS THAT
ATTEMPTED TO DO THIS- OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO WE CAME
TOGETHER FINALLY TO TRY TO
ENACT THE BASIC BILL- THAT WE
COULD ALL AGREE UPON- AT THE
TIME AND WE DID SO. AND THAT
BILL WAS AUTHORED BY IAN
CALDERON IT PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE IN WHICH WE
AGREE TO ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. INCLUDING THE
CEASE CONTACT PROVISION- THEN
IT WOUND UP BEING HELD AT THE
END OF SESSION AND SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE FILE
FOR NO KNOWN REASON. SINCE THE
BILL HAD NO COST SO MUCH
APPRECIATE MARC CO AUTHOR AT
THE TIME- ASSEMBLY WHEN RUBIO
REINTRODUCING THE BILL- AND
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT TO GET
IT PROVIDES. IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR FAMILIES- IN A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME TO KILL THE
NECESSARY- DURING A PANDEMIC
WHEN YOU CAN'T VISIT
FACILITIES- YES THERE COULD
HAVE BEEN A MANY ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS ADDED BUT THIS WAS.
A BILL THAT- WITH INTENDED TO
BE A CAN. ON THE STAR POINT
CALIFORNIA TO MOVE FORWARD PER.
FAMILIES AND CONSUMER A- THIS
BILL DOES THAT SO WITH WOULD
URGE SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR THERE
ANYWAY IN SO. OF MEASURE ANY
ELSE CALL IN FORCE OF THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
NINETY NINE. FIVE FOUR ONE ZERO
NOW. MOVE AB. FOUR NINE NINE.
CORRECT. THE PHARMACY CARE WE
HAVE ABOUT FIVE PEOPLE QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONALIST OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT CENTER LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU CHEN
MEMBERS CATAMARAN WITH AARON
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
A RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
TWENTY THREE A LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
PATRICK CHAN AND REPRESENTING
CARING DOT COM A NATIONAL
SENIOR REFERRAL AGENCY HAS
COSPONSORED IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. Q. NEXT CALL PLEASE.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GLENDA ARE MEANT REPRESENTING
NATIONAL PLACEMENT REFERRAL
ALLIANCE WHICH IS THE NATIONAL
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR REFERRAL
AGENCIES ARE URGING YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR NINE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. ONE POLITE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING HARRISON THE CAL
SYSTEM BEING ASSESSED IN
SUPPORT. AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE I THINK.
GREAT IS THERE ANY ONE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR NINETY
NINE PRESS ONE ZERO. IT WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINEUP
AND TAKE YOU BACK IN Q. ONCE A
IF YOU WISH TO PICK IT UP OF AB
FOR NINE NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN NOW. HOMONYMOUS THIS YEAR
WE HAVE SOMEONE KEEPING UP. WHY
NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
RECTANGLE REPRESENTING SIX BEDS
WHICH IS AN ASSOCIATION- SMALL
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED- HENCE THE NAME FOR
THE SIX MINUTES OF YOUR IN THE
HOME. WE COMMEND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO BE A FOR HER EFFORTS
TO REGULATE AN INDUSTRY THAT'S
GONE UNCHECKED- FOR. SO LONG
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
WORKING WITH MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG US FIVE WE HAVE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED AND EVEN SPONSORED
SIMILAR LEGISLATION IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WE'RE WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT OFFICIALLY IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE REQUESTING AN
AMENDMENT. WE BELIEVE THAT ONE
ENTITY RECEIVES I REQUEST TO
SEIZE CONTACT WE THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY
I WENT INDIVIDUAL REACHES OUT
FOR ALL AGENCY TO TRY FIND A
WHERE ARE RCA B. THEY WITHIN IF
NOT SECONDS FROM ALL THE HOMES
THAT MEMBER FOR TO THEM AS
POSSIBLE PLACES FOR THE ONES.
SO IF THE REFERRAL TAKE PLACE
THAT COULD WE BELIEVE BY ADVICE
REQUIRE TO SEIZE. WE JUST AT
THE STATION. AND NOT ONE AND
CORBELS IN OUR WOULD BE IF I'M
I'M TRYING TO PLAY A LOT BILL.
IN A HOME IN THE AWAY OUR
FAMILIES OUR MORNING AND THEN
BEING IN A BY HOMES FOR OUT TO
PAY MY LEVEL IN ONE OF HOMES
WOULD. EQUAL AS STATUS SO
REQUEST THAT CONTACT BE STATE
ADEQUATE TO SEE FRONT BEING
MADE AND NOT WITHIN THE CURRENT
FIFTY DAYS IS. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S- REQUIREMENT IS
THIRTY DAYS IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
REQUESTING FIFTEEN DAYS- IF
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE.
ORGANIZATIONS TO SEIZE CONTACT-
AT EVEN AS WE WOULD LIKE IT TO
BE NEEDED YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE A PROCESS AND
WE THINK THAT FIFTEEN DAYS IS A
GOOD ENOUGH TIME FRAME LIKE I
SAID FEDERALLY IT'S THIRTY DAYS
AND SO FIFTEEN DAYS GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY- FOR THAT
ORGANIZATION TO COMPLY. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH WITH
THE OPPOSITION- TO TRY AND COME
pTO A CONSENSUS- BUT AT THIS
TIME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE AND ARE WE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH. THEM TO. HEAR THEIR
CONCERNS AND- YOU KNOW WE MAY
OR MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THEM BUT AT LEAST. WE HAVE WILL
BE AND CUT COMMUNICATION WITH
THEM. THANK YOU AND A I. DO
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE AND
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THAT WAS
RAISED BY THE COLLAR AND- SO
THAT I WOULD APPRECIATE YOU
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM
THANK YOU. THERE'S A MOTION AND
A SECOND. LET'S CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF A PAL MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AB
FOUR NINETY NINE NAZARIAN HI
NAZARIAN HI THE PAL. THE PAL I
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I CALDERON CALDERON HI LACKEY
LACKEY I RAMOS RUBIO HI RUBIO I
BILL HAS SIX OF THE DESIGN.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT
BILL AND FINAL BILL IS AB SIX
NINETY FIVE WITH THE MISTER
DOCTOR ARAMBULA. BUT SINCE HE
IS PRESENTING IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO WITH THAT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WHICH INCLUDES- A. B.
NINETY EIGHT. AB TEN EIGHTY
THREE AND A B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN IS THERE A MOTION. GREAT
THANK YOU. CONSENT CALENDAR
MOVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HORVATH AB NINETY EIGHT MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH RECOMMENDED
CONSENTS. AB TEN NINETY EIGHT.
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDED
CONSENT. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDED
CONSENT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN. HI NAZARIAN HI THE
PAL THE PAL I BORN FOR THAT
FORMER FORBATH HI CALDERON
CALDERON HI LACKEY. LACKEY I
RAYOS BLANCA RUBIO I WANT TO
REVEAL BY. THANK YOU AND AT
THIS TIME WE'RE WAITING FOR MR
ARAMBULA WHO- I BELIEVE HIS HIS
BILL IS BEING VOTED UPON RIGHT
NOW SO. WE'LL WAIT FOR A COUPLE
OF MINUTES FOR HIM TO PRESENT
AND AT THIS TIME WHAT I WILL
ASK AGAIN IS. OUR CALL IN
NUMBER FOR WITNESSES IS.
877-692-8957 DEPEND NUMBER
BEING. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. AND IF THERE ARE
ANY ISSUES PLEASE DON'T
HESITATE TO CALL THE COMMITTEE
AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
THREE NINE NINE ZERO. GOOD
MORNING. GREAT TIMING. PLEASE
THE BILL. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA
OBESITY PRESENTING SB SIX
NINETY FIVE YOU HAVE A YOU HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB SIX NINETY
FIVE WILL PROTECT OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS. IN
CALIFORNIA FROM ABUSE NEGLECT
AND EXPLOITATION BY EXPANDING
AND ENHANCING ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. BUT TWENTY THIRTY ONE
IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS WILL BE
AGE SIXTY FIVE OR OLDER. THE
NUMBER OF OLDER ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH DISABILITIES
WILL INCREASE FROM ONE MILLION
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO THREE
MILLION IN TWENTY SIXTY.
CALIFORNIA'S AGING POPULATION
IS ALSO INCREASINGLY SUFFERING
HOMELESSNESS. ACCORDING TO UCSF
RESEARCHERS APPROXIMATELY 50%
OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS ARE
OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY AND HALF
OF THOSE BECAME HOMELESS AFTER
THEY REACHED THE AGE OF FIFTY.
ONE OF THE GREATEST THREATS TO
FULL INCLUSION AND EQUITY FOR
ALL AGES HIS ELDER ABUSE WHICH
IS ESTIMATED TO IMPACT 10% OF
OLDER ADULTS. LIVING AT HOME
AND TO RESULT IN LOSSES
TOTALING IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. TO ADDRESSED
THIS. THE TWO PRONGED ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS AND ELDER ABUSE
EFFECTIVELY THE STATE NEEDS TO
OF INVEST ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
INTO PLANNING AND SUPPORT
SERVICES. TO FILL SUCH A NEED
AB SIX NINETY FIVE WOULD EXPAND
AND ENHANCE THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES FOR OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA. BY INCREASING
COUNTIES CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND BY
BUILDING UPON THE SUCCESSFUL
HOME SAFE PROGRAM TO ASSIST
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICE
CLIENTS WHO NEED HELP WITH
HOUSING ISSUES. BY EXPANDING
THIS OPERATIONAL CAPACITY MORE
OF OUR ELDERLY POPULATIONS CAN
FIND SAFE AND STABLE HOUSING.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
NINETY FIVE. R. KATHY
SANDERLING MCDONALD OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
VIVIENNE MEMBACA- WITH JUSTICE
IN AGING. THANK YOU OPERATOR.
BY THE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
BILLABLE. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HAPPY
THUNDERWING MCCONNELL BUT THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AS A
SPONSOR AT EIGHTY SIX NINETY
FIVE AND A CURRENT BUDGET ASKED
I'M HERE TO PROVIDE THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE WHICH
AIMS TO GROW THE ATF PROGRAM IN
THE HOME SAFE PROGRAM HOUSE
WITHIN APS. TO MEET THE NEEDS
WERE SEEING WITH THE GROWING
OLDER ADULT POPULATION. THE APS
PROGRAM SERVES THE MOST
VULNERABLE OF OUR OLDER AND
ADULTS THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
ABUSED NEGLECTED OR EXPLOITED
AT. THE POPULATION IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING CRISIS
BUT HAS BEEN FURTHER
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC
HOMELESSNESS AMONG THOSE CITY
ASTOR OFTEN BEGINS. WITH ABUSE
NEGLECT OR EXPLOITATION. THESE
OLDER ADULTS OFTEN HAVE CALLED
HEALTH OR MENTAL HEALTH IS THE
CAR. AND SUCH AS DEMENTIA. ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY A FIFTY. ARE
LIVING A PROPERTY THAT FALLEN
INTO DISREPAIR. I DON'T THINK
SO I. A IS ALREADY THESE ALL
ADULTS A PENCIL NEEDS COME HAVE
OF THE PARK. BUT WITHIN
RESOURCES ARE APS FOR. TO GIVE
THEM THE TIME AND ATTENTION
THEY NEED TO FULLY ADDRESS THE
THIS YEAR. THERE'S NOTHING
FUNDING ASIDE FROM SOME FUNDING
FOR TRAINING DEDICATED TO ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICE. AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU WILL MAKE THE
EXISTING HOME SAFE PROGRAM
PERMANENT TO TARGET THOSE ARE
CURRENTLY HOMELESS IN THE FAN
THE PROGRAM TO ADDITIONAL
COUNTY. WE HAVE HEARD FROM
COUNTY THAT THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM HAS SEEN MANY SUCCESSES
AND HELPING OLDER ADULTS. WHO
HAVE DONE AND HAS INCREASED
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS SUCH AS OUR
HOUSING CONTINUUM OF CARE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND HOSPITAL
ALL WORKING TOGETHER TO INSURE
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
SERVING AT HOUSE. PROPERLY
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FIVE SIX
CRITICAL ACTION TO BEGIN TO
PREVENT AND ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. AMONG THE MANY
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS THAT ARE
MOST AT RISK AND WHILE OUR
STAFF TO MORE DEEPLY THIRD THAT
SUBSET OF CASES THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPLEX NEEDS- IN
A WAY THAT ATS NEVER. BOB
INTENDED INTOXICATED OR
IMPORTANTLY FIND AT HIGHER
INTEREST ON SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FIVE AND OF COURSE
I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU AND FOR THE
SECOND WITNESS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS FIFTEEN IN BAKU REPRESENTING
JEFFERSON AGING A CO SPONSORS
OF THIS REQUEST WE ARE ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
NINETY FIVE. ORGANIZATIONS
ACTIVE AGEING BELIEVES THAT NO
MATTER OUR RACE GENDER GENDER
IDENTITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION
ABILITY LANGUAGE OR COUNTRY OF
ORIGIN WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS WE NEED TO PRIVATE
PEOPLE ARE OLDER PEOPLE WE
SUPPORT INCREASED FUNDING FOR
EIGHTY AFTER THEIR INTERVAL AND
FIGHTING THE SYSTEMIC
INEQUITIES THAT AFFECT OLDER
ADULTS OF COLOR IN CALIFORNIA
PURCHASE. PARTICULARLY THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
NUMBERS OF OLDER EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BARBARA AS YOU
JUST HEARD CURRENTLY HAVE THE
BALL HOME ALL OUTDOOR HER OVER
THE OF. AND THE POPULATION IS
EXPECTED TO AND NEXT TEN YEARS.
EVEN MORE CONCERN IS THAT BLACK
OLDER ADULTS FOR OVER. AMONG
THE HOME A POPULAR. IN THE
COUNTRY THIS COUNTRY 43% OF
HOME OF A SOUL OUR WHILE BLACK
PEOPLE MAKE UP WITH 13%
NATIONAL. FIFTY TYPICALLY
EXAMPLE OF THE AFTER EFFECTS OF
DISCRIMINATORY HOUSING
PRACTICES AND GREAT THE TIME.
WHEN THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
AMONG OLDER ADULTS IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY AN EQUITY ISSUE.
INCREASE FUNDING TO APS WILL
DIRECTLY WORK DIRECTLY TO
CREATE MORE ETHICAL AGENT THE
BLACK OLDER ADULTS AND OTHER
OLDER ADULTS OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THE CHANGES THAT
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FIVE MAKE ARE
IMPORTANT TO ATTRACTING EQUITY
ISSUES AMONG OLDER ADULTS. FOR
EXAMPLE PROVIDING RESOURCES FOR
LONGER TERM STAFFING WILL
IMPACT ETF POSSIBLY BY ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
NEEDS OF HOMELESS OLDER ADULTS.
AND PREVENT THE INCREASE AGING
AND. HOUSEHOLDER ADULT. WE KNOW
THAT ORDER TO THAT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS H. THAN THOSE WHO
ARE HOW. MANY HOW MUCH OLDER
HAVE FOUND HAVE NOT CAN THE
FROM CAN TWENTY YEARS OLDER
THAN TO EIGHT. IT'S A VERY OUR
OF HOW. HOME CAN BE. FURTHER A
HOME WITH OLDER ADULTS COLOR
MADE WE OF PERSONAL. AND BEAT
ANY MORE TIME TO BUILD TRUST
WITH THEIR KEY WORKER. MANY
OLDER HOW HAVE THEIR NECK X.
WITH SOCIAL SERVICES IN THE
PAST. AND MAY NEED AND HE
WORKLOAD WILL BE TRACKS.
ADDITIONAL LONG TERM BACK
THINKING THAT THEY BILLION
TRUCK NEEDED TO SERVE OUR OF
ALL. OLDER ADULTS AND PROVIDE A
RESPONSE WITHIN. TO THEM YEAH
HELPING TO CRAFT TRANSFERRED
TRANSITION TO COME HOUSING. AND
IF EXTENDING HOME PAPER AND-
MORE FUNDING WILL IMPACT THE
OLDER POPULATION POP. BY GIVING
APRIL WORKERS IF I COULD THEY
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE. AND A
HOLISTICWAY. HOME STATE BLACK
COUNTY YOU FIND IN WAYS THAT
SUPPORT CLIENT CENTRIC RESPONSE
THAT. WHICH TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
COMP NEEDS ABOUT ARE HOMELESS
AND THAT OF HOMELESSNESS.
JEFFERSON AGING BELIEVE THAT
FUNDING THE EIGHT PROGRAM IS
GOING TO ADDRESSING BOTH THE IS
THE CALL HEARD ALL THANK.
EMIGRATE IN THE ORDER TO
TALKING AND HOW. THE THING I AM
OPEN. IN AND PICKING UP THE CAR
BY AFTER TO ALL OLDER ADULTS IN
THE URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU I MOST PEOPLE
WOULD WITH THAT. AT ANY OF UP
ANY ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MESS. AND JUST AS A REMINDER OF
YOUR IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AND THAT WILL
CALL TWO LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN
ONE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING MISTER CARE
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON THE TO
THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THIS
MORNING I'M SORRY WE'RE LATE WE
DISCOVER A LETTER YESTERDAY
APOLOGETIC BUT- OKAY THANK YOU.
GREAT TIMING THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WILL TO LINE THIRTY THREE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBER MADELINE
COOPER FROM NIELSEN MARKS MORE
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTEEN ONE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
BRONX ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
NEXT DEADLINE THIRTY TWO THREE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING MR
KAREN MEMBERS THERESA ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF THE ARK AND UCPE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT WILL ALIGN
SIXTEEN ONE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PERFECT EXAMPLE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NEXT A LITTLE LINE TWENTY FOUR
TO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEED
A CT WEBER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
CARE UP IN SUPPORT. NEXT A
LITTLE LINE EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUST THINK
HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT WITH
ONLINE THIRTY THREE THREE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM IN THE
MOTOR ERA- IF SUPPORT. AN
ONLINE AT TWENTY NINE TO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHARD
MEMBERS CHARLES TOOL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND THE
CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION WHICH IS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. M. S.
CHAIR NO FOR THEIR LINES IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY CALLS IN
OPPOSITION. NO ANSWER ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
DO HAVE ONE LINE COMING IN ONE
MOMENT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RICHARD CALVIN WITH
CEDAR WE ARE NOT COMPLAINING
ABOUT HOME SAFE WE ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT SECTION FIVE
OF ASSEMBLY BILL SIX. NINE
FIVE. WHICH AMENDS SECTION
FIFTEEN SIX THIRTY OF THE
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
BY EXPANDING MANDATED REPORTERS
THIS WILL RESULT IN A JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO REVISION
DATE WHILE FAILING TO ALIGN
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY FIVE
WITH THE ALREADY EXISTING PENAL
CODE THREE SIXTY POINT FIVE.
PENAL CODE THREE SIXTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE SAYS ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES MAY UPSET
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AT LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
REQUEST AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES RETAIN EXCLUSIVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR
INVESTIGATIONS UNFORTUNATELY
SECTION FIVE SB SIX NINETY FIVE
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED ALLOW
SOCIAL WORKERS TO CONTINUE TO
INTERFERE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS LIST OF RESPONSIBILITIES. BY
CONTINUING TO ALLOW AND
ENCOURAGE MANDATED REPORTING OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY ABUSE THE
SOCIAL WORKERS THAT ARE NOT
TRAINED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
TECHNIQUES AND ARE NOT IRON OR
LACKING IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
WHAT'S- THE SENATE OFFICE OF
OVERSIGHT AND OUTCOMES AT THE
REQUEST OF THIS VERY COMMITTEE.
REPORT IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
IT'S 75% THAT'S THREE QUARTERS
OF REPORTED CASES OF ABUSE
NEVER GET INVESTIGATED BECAUSE
SOCIAL WORKERS REQUIRED TO
BRING A PAYING CONSENT BEFORE
PROVIDING SERVICES AND THEY'RE
UNABLE TO GET CONSENT OF THE
VICTIM LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT
REQUIRE CONSENT. CHEATERS
REQUESTED SIMPLE EITHER TO
LEAVE STRUCTURE A. B. L. FIVE
FOR MAYBE SIX FORTY NINE COOPER
FORMALLY ALIGNED SECTION FIVE
WITH PENAL CODE THREE SIXTY
FIVE POINT FIVE WHICH WOULD
FURTHER ENHANCE THE SERVICES
THAT EVERYBODY CLAIMS THAT THEY
WANT TO BE PROVIDING THESE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND OTHER
CALL. I FOR THEIR LINES AND ANY
A CALL AND OR OPPOSITION FROM
VIDEO CONFERENCING I'M ASSUMING
NOT OKAY GREAT- BEFORE
ANSWERING THAT CONCERN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RESPOND TO THAT WANT TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YES MISTER LUCKY. FIRST FALLS
INSTEAD LEARNED THAT I'M NOT
ONLY AN ELDER MY CHURCH BUT
THROUGH THIS DEFINITION WELL IT
WAS INTERESTING- AND I'M JUST.
THE POINT THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
BY THE PERSICO AGAIN FROM.
CEDARS I I'M I'M IN HOPES THAT
YOU- ARE PLANNING TO RECOGNIZE
THOSE CONCERNS AND TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH. THEM WAS
IDENTIFIED IS THAT CORRECT WE
ARE TAKING A LOOK AT THE LETTER
AND ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. OKAY WELL I
THANK YOU FOR ADVOCATING FOR A
PART OF OUR POPULATION THAT-
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE
OVERLOOKED SO. I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND
OF ANY CLOSING COMMENTS YOU
ALREADY. IT BRIEFLY RESPOND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK
THANK YOU. LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN BLANCA RUBIO AB
SIX NINETY FIVE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
NAZARIAN HI NAZARIAN I'D THE
PAL. THE PAL HI FOR ABOUT ONE
OF HER MOUTH HI CALDERON
CALDERON FIVE LACKEY LACKEY I
READ IS READY AS I LONGER RUBIO.
CONSENTS THE BILL HAS SEVEN
CHIEF JUSTICE. THE BILL HAS
SEVEN OF THE TOP FANTASTIC
THANK YOU OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
REYES FINE I. EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY NINE. READ REYES AYE.
GREAT WE'RE DONE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.